[Music]
[Applause]
all right boys and you get some light
beers right thanks see ya see you
tomorrow
do you think there's a swampy enough for
us all right follow me
[Music]
you are dangerous there are a lot of
reasons yeah it gets its it gets deep
over here yeah whoa big wasp good wasp
yeah oh it's deep okay
why'd you guys go push through it yeah
you just swim underneath it oh look at
the spikes on that tree that's like a
death tree because it's the most
unfriendly tree that tree does not like
tree huggers
[Music]
Tommy has an imaginary pet alligator
that's following us
his name is Chomper isn't that right
little tickle spiders huh
you help you guys yeah keep going
straight boys yeah you got a good path
there tom yeah land ho careful tom
that's where the snakes like to hang out
they like to hang out on the land now
normally being on land is bad for the
snakes because this is how they Sun
themselves the clouds came in so it's
not sunny anymore I just don't want
another banana spider in my face oh my
goodness
whoo those are the creepiest spiders
hurry up guys there's a there's a rain
storm coming
all right guys we found ourselves a
little bit of Highland and there's some
trees here that we can start using to
build camp it's got to be really careful
a lot of poison ivy around here that is
right there that's poison ivy that's
poison ivy that's poison ivy that on the
trees poison ivy you can tell it's got
the three leaves and then it's got the
little like like a thumb on the outside
all right guys you ready to build camp
that's right rains coming get you guys
some place dry
here's my Japanese pocket knife I love
this thing all right we better get this
tarp up I hear some thunder in the
background I think it's gonna rain here
soon
here comes there we go guys we got the
tarp up you guys staying out of the rain
all right let's get the hammocks all
right we got mosquito net and hammocks
and we're gonna need both all right
luckily I brought one of the most
important pieces of survival gear a
handkerchief feed off anything that
touches the ground is muddy grimy wet
and stinky so you the hammocks cannot
touch the ground and this is hard to do
so you do just wrap it around your neck
and work that way so that you don't drop
your hammock Wow I got that tarp up just
in the nick of the time and got both the
boys hammocks up and they're sharing a
mosquito net and that seems to be
working really well I get a third
hammock and suck it mosquito net up and
then we'll be in a little bit of a room
to breathe I've got a problem with my
brand-new hammock you know how there's
the string on a hoodie and if you pull
it on one side it'll just the string
will come out and your hoodies
drawstring is kind of done that's what's
happened to my hammock now I'm trying to
redo it really quick uh-huh I got it oh
man
the rain has brought the bugs out but
I've got the boys out of the rain and
under the tarp now I need to worry about
food oh man I just I need something to
cook on and a way to cook out of the
rain and out of the mud so we're gonna
see what we come up with if the bugs
aren't as bad as you would expect in the
Bayou except at sunset and when it rains
and it's they're just terrible right now
so I'm gonna put on some of this Ultron
12 hour bug repellent this is the good
stuff this is is some of the best bug
repellent you can get so we'll see if it
works
oh I'm walking through a lot of spider
webs oh all this right here is poison
ivy and the sap is what gifts you and so
I got to make sure not to touch the
blade or anything that's touched the
poison ivy
[Music]
[Music]
this is that thorn tree so gotta take
all the thorns off it boys Nathan that's
really bad for the mosquito netting okay
[Music]
all right guys less roughhousing in the
hammocks okay
[Music]
what is in there how something just
stung you between my toes and it really
hurts
I think this plant must be like some
sort of stinging nettle
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
yeah your pick chameleon is riding the
tree right I'm so proud of Tommy and
they they've been in that hammock for a
couple hours now and they've been
entertaining themselves wonderfully all
they've got is a mayonnaise jar with a
chameleon and a tree frog in it oh yeah
all right there we go got it done
well you know this platform is pretty
solid you don't need to lash the decking
together just the compression of
everything squeezed tightly together
keeps it in place it's a little bit
better I can see a little bit more yeah
you can push yourself with your feet
yeah yeah how it works well I've been
swept my brains out man I gotta get some
water in me so we're gonna do some cool
water purification techniques
when you look at the swamp water around
here the word stagnant and putrid comes
to mind so wouldn't recommend drinking
it straight so what we're gonna do is
we're gonna use a product called
chlorophyll akka chlorinated water kills
bacteria and viruses and then it makes
all the sediment and suspended material
fall to the bottom and then we can
filter it out really easy and so it
makes the water not only safe but tastes
a heck of a lot better too so you put
about one or two of these packets per
liter we got three liters in here so so
I'm gonna go full-throttle and put six
packets in once you've added the package
you shake this for one full minute let
it sit for 30 seconds then shake it
again a little bit then let it sit for
at least 15 minutes there we go that's a
minute we let this sit for a little
while I'm gonna straighten up camp and
then we're gonna shake it some more and
we'll have drinking water when you're
just wallowing in mud like this you just
gotta have a platform the boys here are
change it into their jammies and they
need some place to stand and they can do
it without getting out of the bug net
it's just so important
[Applause]
well guys the Sun is setting quickly
here in the Bayou and we need to eat
dinner and so we are gonna make fried
frog jambalaya and I have a bag of four
live yellow throat frogs that mean the
boy is caught last night with our bare
hands if you guys would like to see that
video and see our week long excursion
here in the Bayou we have caught and
cooked gar and blue catfish and buffalo
and blue crabs the ball huge blue crabs
we were down here with Cajun experience
and if you don't know who those guys are
I'll put a link in the description if
you want to see our week-long adventure
I'll put a link to that video as well so
definitely check that out
but I have got to butcher and cook up
some frogs I'll tell you guys fried frog
legs are no joke one of the best things
ever but we're gonna try to jambalaya
Sal today Fenian frogs is pretty easy
just chop off the head remove the feet
take off the skin and the guts for frog
legs in a pot well by now the claw Rock
has really done its job look how clear
that water is and there's all this junk
down here on the bottom a little bit
still floating in it but we're gonna
filter those out
all right we're gonna put some Cajun
seasoning on these uh these frog legs
and get them nice and flavorful let that
sit the seasonings making the frogs
twitch and jump that's when you know
it's fresh that creepy my pots too small
for these frog legs I got a quarter them
there we go all right now
now they fit in the pot nicely now we're
gonna fry up a bunch of vegetable all
right now we've got this Cajun spicy
jambalaya mix here bring add in there
that's looking pretty good just bring
that to boil I'm gonna simmer it for a
while should be ready
my legs sure are gross but the
mosquitoes love them we're really
putting our bug repellent to the test I
mean there are just a ton of mosquitoes
in here I haven't seen this many
mosquitoes since I was a boy in Alaska
well that Ultron bug repellent works
pretty good and it doesn't burn or smell
nasty like deep does but you really got
to cover every nook and cranny with it
or they will find a sweet spot you want
some jambalaya don't spill in there
remember this is your bed you tell me
what do you think it's a little spicy
yeah that's Cajun food
well I think the frogs and jambalaya
tastes delicious but the boys here
disagree so we have a fallback plan
hot dogs who's ready for some hot dogs
okay grab that don't spill them well I
just finished dinner and I can hear tons
of bullfrogs and yellow thread frogs out
here around us and we're gonna see if we
can't catch some I am wearing this
high-powered headlamp on my head and I'm
shining it around looking for the blue
light of frog eyes and if I shine the
light in their eyes they'll hold still
long enough I can get up to them and
hopefully grab one but it also makes all
the spiders and other creepy crawlies in
in the swamp make their eyes glow as
well I can see all of these twinkling
lights there are thousands and thousands
of spider eyes here in this swamp kind
of cool kind of disconcerning
that was a big bullfrog
I've already seen three frogs in a very
short period of time
dang it I was so close to that one
oh geez there's some big bullfrogs here
broken turtle eggs oh there was a bunch
of bullfrogs they're like sneaking up on
these guys was a bit much they were
really really gun-shy luckily we had a
really successful frog hunting catch and
cook trip earlier this week so I'll put
a link in the description to some of our
our other videos where we were a little
more successful catching frogs but it is
late and it's time to get to bed so I'm
gonna tuck these guys in and we're a
call for the night
I do not have a clue how it would change
out of these muddy clothes if I didn't
have this platform and sit on
holy mackerel all right let's get to it
mosquitoes are gonna love this part
let's see Tommy you in here mate you in
here yeah all right I'm here
we got three hammocks under one tarp a
whole three of us are right in each
other's business this is close quarters
all right guys let's see if we can get
to sleep Oh guys I gotta tell you that
was one of the roughest nice sleeps I've
ever had right before I fell asleep I
was in my skivvies and I flipped my
hammock fell into the mud and I tore a
hole in the mosquito netting and I had
to jump out in my underwear and fix the
mosquito netting fixed the platform fix
the hammock re-rig and the bugs ate me
alive because I only had bug repellent
on my arms and legs and so I've got
dozens and dozens of bites where the Sun
don't shine and I have been itching and
itching itching all night long I am
usually the 1 or 2 mosquito bites don't
do that much for me but I probably have
100 mosquito bites if you total up all
over my arms I mean my arms and my back
are just like bumpy look at that he's
biting me through my shirt oh well guys
I am NOT gonna hang out in this paradise
for too long I know Nathan got ate up a
whole bunch too and he's been all itchy
so I'm gonna start cleaning up the camp
and we're gonna pack up I'm gonna find
myself the biggest tub of Benadryl cream
and we're just gonna just go crazy
good morning tom you get a little bit of
ice too well Tommy did you have a good
time
it was a little rough but I'm glad we
came and I'm glad you came with me buddy
look man there's a lot of things I would
do differently falling out of the
hammock in the middle of the night and
your underwear it's really a bad idea
whoo Oh
all right guys we're out of here oh I
got to tell you man you look like Prince
Charming on a white stallion when you
came in with that boat whoo
why mosquitoes
well that was adventurous and I've been
wanting to try that for a while but I'm
glad it's over man I am so covered in
bug bites so I got any bug bites on my
back oh my arm
oh look at that holy crap that's a lot
of pot pies oh man it feels good to be
showered and in clean clothes again oh
oh we've had such a great time here with
Cajun experience we've been staying here
on their houseboat for five days also if
you guys want to see more from this trip
including all the frogging and catching
catfish and just the whole experience
itself I'll put a link in the
description to that video as well but
thanks for watching guys we hope you
enjoy this don't forget to click
Subscribe we put out new videos every
Saturday morning if you like this video
don't forget to check out the outdoor
boys youtube channel where we have
hundreds of videos just like this and
don't forget to click subscribe so you
can see other great videos every
Saturday morning and hit that Bell
button you'll get notifications thanks
for watching